hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's 2 this is it last night the
very end of the game hahaha and I'm sure
that nothing bad is gonna happen
afterwards and we're all gonna go home
with Sunshine's and rainbows and flowers
in our hair we're gonna have a happy fun
time well you know what's happening
you're dead you're not alive you're
you're you're the guy you're probably
golden freddy probably is the least foxy
decided to leave me alone yeah I know
that they're gonna be coming after me
they're gonna be coming after me lucky
charms
gonna be coming after my giblets I'm
sure also known as to be lucky charms
apparently but apparently I'm turning
into jacksepticeye but I can't do that
because I got freddy fazbear's we go run
in on my luck and I don't know what to
do about it
so either way let's not be weird just
yet let's just get this done and out of
the way so that we can go home
well I mean go home and definitely not
come back for a six-night for no reason
can it's not happen right now I'm not
gonna be fast enough am i okay this is
95 this is serious business this means
that they're gonna be crawling all over
me and I'm never gonna have a single
damn break so I need to be ready with it
in it out it do it to it and then could
blew it then be to blow something that
matter what the same thing gonna be fine
so long as I keep the baby asleep so
long as nothing it's my brains oh boy
why would they eat my brains
so how they be human again come on I
can't spend a lot since I turn that on
I'd love to be able to turn that on t
there we go mangles fine on a mine
spider foxy mangle is much easier just
like the marionette is not an easier
name than the baby so I'm gonna call
that I know you could be here
[Applause]
I can't put them on Milo there god
dammit I wasn't ready for you to be more
of an alert yeah fine this is what's
complicated about it I know that there's
got to be some methodology to looking
around the area which is fine I greatly
appreciate how that is but I just wish I
was able to do it a little bit easier Oh
God
still aware of the new animatronics are
they even out they're not are they okay
that guy's not there yet no no no no no
god damn it with that thing and the
thing in the thing hello okay mangles
taking this time to get over here spider
fox ffox
he's a dick so I'll shut up maybe I
shouldn't be insulting all the
animatronics while they try to rip my
brains out come on where are ya Bonnie
he's not even in the vest yet that's
good that's bad that's bad God shows us
audio cube maybe there is an audio cue
I just don't know it yet I think he's in
the vents now mangles also in the vents
Oh like I might be spending way too much
time out here okay then maybe that's why
the music's like that it's like it's
telling me hey get out of the camera hey
stop looking at all that yeah look at
that horn right stop that but when I'm
not doing that not looking at oceans and
oceans of porn but when I'm actually
monitoring these dudes maybe I need to
be in the camera more because that would
give me more time and then I can utilize
the audio clues to be able to know what
I'm supposed to do when I'm responding
to it oh whoa hello are you here no he's
not okay
don't be like that you're not here yet
oh maybe that's the dynamic of the game
that's changed maybe that could be in
here is Ojai new Freddy you're looking
funtastic oh boy okay fine
[Music]
you can't tell me that lost yeah and
Bonnie's on the way to so Baba okay see
got your number pop up yeah nothing
coming to get me well that's okay so can
I do down there okay that's fine
I need to see down there can you let me
stay down there I really like to see
down there there we go Bonnie's back
already
Bonnie just made a big circle you know
you want to go nowhere okay so kids in
the band that's okay so start being
Oh goddamn why is he still here okay
we're fine yep okay people are moving
all over the place I don't much care for
it huh
still can't goddamn with that hallway
[Music]
okay ready
god damn it's even worse when Freddie
comes up the big guy here they're not
supposed to kill me oh that is a blind
panic but it's doable it's doable I just
didn't hear him before I had a chance to
react I need to always cuz it kind of
blends in come on let me do it on
hallway please
thank you oh this new was clambering
around
[ __ ] me
Jesus get stupid chicken a my dad I'm
not dead okay
thankfully not dead yet oh man how's it
still chew him
there's some ball is some level of bow
that I have never seen before
Oh God that was not quick enough
[Applause]
god with the thing
who is there's got to be a rule after
2:00 a.m. never could put down the
camera without putting on the hood
that's just got to be a rule gotta be a
rule oh god damn it
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ]
me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me how's it
going
oh okay
[Music]
hello you okay
wind it up wind it up wind it up why did
it wind it up we're no one's here
Freddie's there everyone's having a good
time
backed up - alright we're back in it
house a bit of a crisis there everyone
was kind of hitting us at once that's
okay it's all good it's all good
Oh Freddie's back again who's clamoring
who's clamoring ready ready ready ready
ready is my name whoa okay I can
remember me out here
sound noise I'm hearing in there okay I
got ya I got you new chica
come on come on yeah yeah I know you're
there I know you're there who wants to
be flashed next yeah so you do chica all
right I'll flash you till the dusk is
dawn don't worry about me
I got unlimited stores of flashing
energy because I'm very conservative Oh
yep this is how we do not let me fly
down the hallway something's coming
after me if it's goddamn foxy oh you're
not here if it's got a foxy oh [ __ ] me
Fox is gonna charge me
dammit dammit there we go there we go
there we go there we go there we go
hi was that you oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god let me guess
I can take it look Craig what Craig up
man gonna take it again just go dress
dress
good go do you turn over to sex
damn you damn all of you now good yes
turn over the friggin six I know it's
coming but who's going I know I deserve
it
I earned this Jeremy Fitzgerald and my
birthday was 187 no there's not gonna be
a secret god damn it there's a six-night
well hope you all were here for more
five nights at Freddy's because not only
is there a sick side I'm willing to bet
that there's going to be huh seven
tonight with a customizable mode so
there you go thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for even
more five nights at Freddy's or my giant
scary games playlist is one hundred and
fifty videos or more check it out thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]